I'm good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is for Quebec on and i would like
to welcome you here on behalf of my
colleague John midscale who
unfortunately can't be here as the
executive director of the Institute for
the Study of Europe and also as the
director of the East Central European
studies centre here but I have been
asked therefore to stand in for him I'm
a historian of Central Europe here in
the history department and I would like
to welcome all of you most cordial ease
thank you for coming and I'm sure we
will have a very interesting evening
discussion afterwards also but I would
like to extend a special welcome of
course to our speaker mr. ball to broken
bells Ravitch former Deputy Prime
Minister finance minister a governor of
the National Bank of Poland and an
economics professor still and at the
moment and that's why I'm very glad that
we were able to adore him here to
Columbia this afternoon a visiting
professor at Brown University at the
moment and the second person I would
like to introduce and talk a little bit
about him because there are many
interesting connections between him and
our speaker is mr. John Burland who will
then introduce the speaker in a moment
so if you allow me just to say a few
words about him he is a businessman here
in New Yorker former CEO of dylan and
read the very well known investment firm
he is now still a partner in saratoga
partners here in New York also but I
think secondly I would like to emphasize
that he is a philanthropist he has been
involved with brown university for many
years he endowed one of the chairs at
Brown University he's also or was the
chair of the National Humanities Center
in North Carolina for several years and
he is also a member of the trustees of
the American Academy in Berlin and
finally I should
engine that he has been involved with
institute for the study of europe and
european studies for many years here at
columbia university thirdly he is also
and this is I hope not a claim that he
will be embarrassed by he is a fellow
historian because he has written a book
on gustav stresemann the German Foreign
Minister in the 1920s and in those years
as you probably know the German
government of course was very much
involved with attracting also American
loans for the reconstruction revival not
just of the German economy but of the
European economy inn in general and
raise a man and dylan and read i should
say in those years were also very much
involved in that particular Enterprise
that then very sadly faltered in 1929
and then fourthly and finally he has
also been very much involved with the
Polish American Enterprise Fund and I
think he in fact was the driving force
behind setting this up in this country
in the early 1990s and I think it is in
this context that mr. Birkeland met
minister bal Tsarevich and that is what
I'm sure he will want to talk about a
little by introducing our speaker so
thank you John for agreeing to be here
this evening
first of all it's an it's an honor to be
here particularly because my old friend
professor burg Han is here and the
gracious introduction thank you very
much I am truly honored to introduce
leszek Bell Tsarevich and his lovely
wife he is one of my heroes and I won't
spend too much time extolling him and
his career other than to say that he is
a scholar of great repute and a
statesman and add to that he was a
politician as well he has he graduated
from the University of Warsaw or primary
Warsaw School of Economics in 1970 and
in 1974 he got his MBA in st. John's
University here in New York and a 1975
he had a PhD in Warsaw so he's been
educated on both sides of the Atlantic
and he has a view of the world in
nineteen October 1990 he was asked to
head to become deputy prime minister and
minister of finance of a government that
would be in power on january first and
during those three months or four that
even he and his colleagues developed a
plan for the transformation of Poland
on january first they lifted price
controls they freed this Lahti and they
took this enormous risk on inflation in
the hope that product would come in to
free the markets and to reduce inflation
and they were right it was probably the
most effective transformation if I may
say so from a communist government to a
free society that has yet occurred the
particular experience that I would like
to relate is that when I was asked by
president pushed to a chair the Polish
American Enterprise Fund we had 240
million dollars and we were supposed to
help him reform Poland with 240 million
dollars and so he was one of the first
people I met in May nineteen ninety in
Poland and I said well what do you think
we should be doing here and he said well
with 240 million dollars you can't do
very much but here's what I suggest and
he handed me a memorandum which is staff
had prepared and which was aimed at a
small loan program to facilitate credit
for small businesses throughout Poland
all of which were starving for credit
well we took his advice and that became
a quite well known small loan program
which we developed within Poland through
the banks and I think we extended loans
to something like a hundred thousand
enterprises we had a two percent loss
ratio which is quite remarkable if you
know anything about this and then we
went on to do other things in Poland of
a similar variety investing in small
companies and so forth and throughout I
had occasion now and then to encounter
my friend he entered politics in as head
of a political party dedicated to a free
society and free enterprise and then in
nineteen ninety it might have hardened
me in two thousand he became
president of the Bank bet of the Bank of
Poland and he's been in that spot from
1990 until this year through a very
difficult period in which the bank of
Poland probably was one of the best
manage banks in Central Europe in fact
I'd say it was the best he has degrees
from all sorts of places and I won't
mention them about twelve them all over
the Western world and he has published
quite a number of articles and books he
has been honored and you will be
interested to know this but by the
ludwig erhard institute dedicated to
free enterprise by the Friedrich von
Hayek in Institute which is also
dedicated to free enterprise and by the
Karl bertelsmann you got to park Karl
bertelsmann prize for the same sort of
experience I have had the privilege of
following his career for 17 years and
there are very few people that I have
known that have made a greater impact in
a more important place than my friend
mr. Belzer Ravitch
thank you very much John for this
extremely kind introduction my topic
institutional institutional center of
the community is very proud and I have
30 to 35 minutes so I have to be very
selective I will welcome questions after
my presentation to understand what has
happened after the collapse of communist
you have to understand communism to some
extent our community as an institutional
system has several distinguishing
features first all kinds of individual
freedoms are very much constraint or in
other words in other words state
controls or political controls were
extensive what were these controls well
you could not create and develop private
enterprise so economic freedom was
eliminated it could not enter into
market relationships because they were
appraised by central planning money was
not convertible which meant that had
Kyle's was rationed free trader was a
practical event and passports were not
kept at home media were controlled so
whole list of controls and economic
control is not on the handbag economy
but also produce dependence on
individuals upon political authorities
take the Wrekin convertibility of money
if not only economic issues a political
issue because if money is not converted
and you want to go abroad if I out to
you have two are to write a petition to
the authority so that they kindly grant
you one hundred dollars and if you are
disobedient you can't obtain this handle
$150 so extremely broad set of controls
in other words lack of freedoms all
kinds of freedoms severe economic and
political second as a reverse site of
this situation there was a special
political regime there was a huge
concentration of political power in
society
the head of party state there was a low
but there was no rule of law playing
upon the words a little i think in
german they know this of worship you in
other words the content of the legal
frame valuated certain tenants of the
rule of law like predictability like the
fact that it is the law and not
arbitrary power which governs in the
society there are also constitutions and
some of them they are very beautiful in
content the point was that the main the
most beautiful parts of the Constitution
were not binding upon the authorities
and it was a very risk and everybody
knew it to try to use this beautiful
parts of the Constitution so one can say
that there were constitutions without
constitutionalism because the IDF
Constitution was as you know implies a
limited government and this government
was obviously not a limited third there
are there was a special i would call
social welfare state and this was in
itself a more pleasant part but it was a
piper a by-product of non pleasant parts
of the regime so footstep were cheap
because they were hugely subsidized
energy was cheap hugely subsidized there
was no fear of up an unemployment
because the economy also its full given
the lack of competition and opening that
was what we call disguised unemployment
so unemployment on the job but from the
point of view of affected individual is
always more pleasant to be unemployed on
the job that in an open way from the
point of view of economic development
the reverse is true now there are some
other features which one can be derived
from these ones I sleep them aside I
wanted to stage the three or four
features because they make you realize
that if the countries where communist
collapsed wanted to build say a
western-type
additional system which is a combination
of rule of law market economy and
democracy then had they had a huge or
gender huge this was not on the one
transformation there were several
transformation going on ad at the same
time well in the political system there
was a transition from dictatorship of a
special kind to democracy in a legal
system you have to move from a low
Laszlo to rule of law which of course it
implied a lot of necessary changes
including first of all limits on
political power which includes among
other things independent judiciary and
in modern times during modern times
independent central bank now you have to
move from the media formed by lifting
censorship and by providing me a girl go
private there was a tremendous no
transition from media who are boring
because they have to piece the rulers
not the masses to the media which are
free and hopefully competent so several
transitions going on where necessary and
you can say with the benefit of
hindsight it some countries make more of
these transitions some countries have
less of transitions the general speaking
and this explains largely the
differences in outcomes and let me come
now to some observation but a benefit of
heights yes what can we say having the
experience of 17 years of actual
development after the collapse of
transition I again I am going to be very
selective I made seven points there may
be hundred if you are in disaggregated
fashion first there are an even
political developments after a brief
period of overall universal political
leader Liza
some countries went back why some other
countries maintained democracy which
countries were back I am speaking about
post-communist world belarus
Turkmenistan Uzbekistan the her special
question of Russia which I will leave
aside during this introduction what's
interesting is that countries which went
back on political liberalization and
became again dictator did not reform the
economy so you don't have pro-market
dictatorships which existed in the work
like in South Korea in the sixties and
the general park all the post communist
dictatorships are anti market right
bunker speculate why I perhaps because
they knew the dictators are former
communist party secretaries all the
directors of co-hosts like Lukashenko in
on in a villa rooster I think their
wealth unsound the world view they
experience not necessary teaches them
what's the market economy and the rule
of law second we have a lot of research
empirical research which shows that the
more you reform the economy the better
the results and they are huge
differences in the results that though
does it mean the more you reform the
economy when you have at the beginning
their command economy right get a
Eurasian meeting you remove the central
controls up on economic freedom if you
do that market emerges because market is
got a cooperation between people and
people are free then following the
interest they enter into market
relationships to be sure some market
requires more than freedom simple market
require on the freedom that sufficient
spot markets but financial markets in
addition to freedom they require
institution and the pickings good
accounting etc etc that freedom is
absolutely essential for the market
economy it means privatization
you can't have market economy the longer
way which would consist mostly of
state-owned enterprises because theta
enterprises are politicized how where is
the ultimate power in the hands of
politicians and in the hands of
subordinated her bureaucrats and this is
why and this is the universal experience
state-owned enterprises being
politicized perform portal and they can
survive on the under one condition there
is no competition and there's no
accident that all calm music honors were
closed because they consisted only of
state-owned enterprises once you open
the economy and you don't privatized and
sooner or later state-owned enterprises
go bust bankrupt and people lose their
job even though the popular cliches that
privatization produces unemployment
where the reverse is true because
without privatization pipes in the
longer run that much more unemployment
because state-owned enterprises cannot
face the competition and as I said there
is a strength empirical evidence on the
link in the longer run between the
extent of market reforms and such
indicators of the standard of reading as
a growth of gdp decline of inflation
infants of G FDI let me only mentioned
that say Holland even though reforms
wink last year were not very fast to say
the least but if you take hey they hold
last 17 years in Poland in 2005 the GDP
equaled one forty seven percent of the
initial level in 1989 then we've got
slovak republic the Baltics that if you
look at Russia the registred is the GDP
equaled was only eight seven percent of
the initial 80 90 so huge differences in
other indicators too in other words
reform economic reforms a very important
social meaning for the people if you do
not reform but you inherit bank rate
economy you heart the people by not
reforming very much there is no much if
you look at the data because this is an
empirical issue there's not much room
for doubt but what's more interesting or
equally interesting is let her economic
outcomes go hand in hand with non
economic outcomes sometimes people say
well if you reform the economy than you
achieve better economic results but
people pay the price social price well
if you buy so surprised me in health
environment the reverse is true those
countries which we found them more more
on the economy corner they achieve
better results on health better results
on environment there is a lot of daytime
come to that in the discussion why
probably because there are some common
reasons say Sasha's economy was
extremely wasteful and ecological
economically it use an average for three
four five times as much energy per unit
of national income say one below but
being so wasteful economical it was also
ways through ecological because the use
of energy has environment even though we
cannot survive without a mature so by if
you reform the economy you make it more
efficient it's like anal energy
incentive imagined in concert and in
this way either becomes more
environmental frontal so those say also
this by-product and if you look at the
data for life expectancy you see the
same Pollard life expectancy for both
sexes not only for stronger sex meaning
the ladies have increased by three four
years while so fine Ukraine despair is
the crying a little I didn't rush in
decline by three years to the show not
only for economic reasons now
so economic reforms bring about not on
the economic benefits but on
non-economic benefits too if you look at
their respective types of economic
reforms then you can see get the most
advanced countries do different value
later on privatization extent of private
entities but most of them are already
private account they differ very little
I mean deck advanced countries which are
the more first of all central Eastern
European countries on external
liberalisation the other rope and
successful open I can see the largest
difference with respect to fiscal
reforms you know some countries like
Poland Hungary Czech Republic have a
premature Swedish model people sometimes
come here susceptible a Pharisee day
whenever economists say spending is too
large tax assessor results are too high
they say that Sweden and they look so
point out the finger that Sweden saying
this is a success story and should
remember that spending to deterioration
in Poland Hungary then more it's now
higher as a percentage of GDP again in
Sweden when sweden at the same per
capita income has fallen log which was
in 1963 and we should compare comparable
countries so in the sense these some of
these four sources economists have
premature Swedish model which is a drag
on growth because it produces taxes high
taxes high spending and disincentives to
work another observation would be that
the liberalization comprehensive
liberalization had enormous importance
cannot be overestimated
because the liberalization means just
the extent freedoms so you dismantle
controls because it's thanks to the
organization we got rid of shortages we
became competitive but also
liberalization meaning the freedom to
set up new enterprises produces a lot of
institutional innovation in the command
economy the decision to set new
organization reconsecrated at the top
and they're a very routine if you let
people organize feeling they come out
with lots of innovations not only
technological innovations but also
organizational innovations because then
everybody you have you multiply the
number of capable people ten times
hundred times and you see so
liberalization is very important however
some people say this is pretty
fashionable among some analysts that
institutions were neglected they say
meaning that courts are not yet
efficient administration efficient they
rarely say what do they mean by
neglected if they say it's better that
we have packet institutions that's okay
but you could not have perfect
institutions from the very beginning
there was only one country which was
able to dismantle all the institutions
which was this country and important
source so to say from outside this was
East Germany because this country was a
sort of taken over peacefully with lots
of data mark billions and billions and
billions by West Germany but it was
impossible i would say fortunately
impossible to do it in Poland Hungary
Slovakia which means that you could not
dissolve all the enterprise's you could
not dissolve or the administration you
have to restructure them and it takes
time
since it takes more time that to enact
new legislation you have a certain time
Deb dime lake you have first new
legislation which is very important but
on the later you have a more efficient
cause because judges take time to learn
than you know so in the meantime the law
is not very well enforced that's true
but does it mean it would be better to
delay the new legislation I don't think
so because this new legislation is
extremely important for giving rise to
new activities market econ etc and sign
legislation could not just simply wave
it because in fact you would have to
maintain a command economy lots of
controls so the best solution in my mind
and this is I think confirmed that a lot
of research was to start a comprehensive
program at about the same time and to
move to try to move at the max speed
which is close their maximum one but
differs depending on the reform and then
you first have a immature market economy
without good institutions but if you
persist institutions improve so you've
got a better market economy if you
persist now another observation would be
that constitutions which are exterior
anomaly rule of law country constitution
medals if a country has a legal system
without rule of law constitutions do not
matter in the sense that they do not
constrain the political power but as we
have moved to a rule of law situation
Constitution started to matter and then
with this there were two problems or two
phenomenon SF a on the whole the new
constitutions contained not only the
classical list what the philosopher and
political scientists call negative
rights or
which this is the essence of freedom but
also a quite an impressive list of what
is called sometimes positive rights or
entitlement all kinds rights to which
require a lot of others people money and
this is this kind of Western European
model and the question is to what extent
there is going to be a clash between
dispositive rights which requires a lot
of taxes India enforce and deliver this
which are necessary for freedom to
flourish and for the economy to grow and
this is very much depends on the
interpretations down like constitutional
Tribunal's the second interesting issue
is that what extend the rulings of
Constitution Tribunal's which aren't a
new phenomenon which is the counterpart
of supreme court in the US are respected
because it's not enough to for the
Constitutional Tribunal to say this is
not consistent with Constitution where
this has to be recognized in practice
and for example in Poland for the last
two years we had not on the last two
years cigar Saturdays there was a
problem that constitutional tribunal
recognize a certain piece of legislation
as not combative with the Constitution
but it remained on the books i would say
although i think constantly the
Constitution where the Constitution is
truly binding depends have actively
people are involved in defending a
constitution there is never a good
Constitution without active involvement
of the people in the defense of good
Constitution Constitution by itself
saying that you write some damn thing
it's not going to be binding and this is
probably the biggest role urge to make
people feel that they are citizens and
they are responsible for the shape of
the system society now
let me finish I want to as I said to
leave as much time as possible to make a
few points about how to explain
difference as I said there are huge
differences in the extent of reforms how
to explain these differences this
belongs to what the economy is called
political economy of change believe and
this is much more speculative than
economics is relatively easy to show why
progressive taxation hats the economic
growth it's more difficult to explain
why countries differ in the extent of
reforms surplus I would only make two or
three points first the situation of the
country's objectively different also due
to some extent of to history market
reforms could be linked either to
positive things or to negative things
depending on the country say in central
Eastern Europe market reforms could be
linked to a positive things which was
called enlargement so this linked to the
perspective of entering their European
you rate them imported incentive role
this was not available ultra center in
Eastern Europe to be sure this does not
explain everything because we have
countries which have no possibilities to
enter the European Union but turn out to
be extremely brave reformers like
Armenia Romania is a brave reformer but
certainly deck the possibility to linked
market reforms which do not necessarily
very poor positive to something which is
positive which is popular matters and
our differences in this or say in the
Baltic I think that both market reforms
were linked in the popular perception to
preserving the independence I think the
idea turanians and the people of Estonia
the actor I realized that without market
reforms they cannot be independent and
they have this highly developed feeling
of national conscious which was not
present or not because of historical
reasons he say belarus second as in
during the wall you cannot explain the
battles without analyzing the
commander's it's not only soldiers the
commander's the same goes for reforms
personalities network in the sense how
quickly a capable of moving and using
the windows of opportunities where they
are capable of managing their program or
not this is not I think that it matters
and in reforming one should not have any
illusion from the very beginning that
one can be very popular for the odd all
the time i am not saying one should like
being in popular that's not good but i
would like to make a point that you
cannot avoid this component sandisk
intend even if you are no successful
with economic reforms so you are very
successful after the collapse economy is
growing inflation is following still
there will be a lot of discontent why
because if you are successful with
reforming the system you change the
relative positions meaning let's say in
Poland and the socialism what category
of people professional categories at the
top besides the Politburo which was not
very large the miners coal miners they
were privileged both in wages and
interest is why because the specialist
economy being very wasteful needed a lot
of energy and wise and miners have to be
rewarded correspondingly who was at the
bottle at the scale hill to remember
socials accountants why because
anti-socialist costs did not matter you
did not need to calculate costs
now say you are very successful with
reforms what is happening miners are
going down the relative terms even
though over time they may be getting
better and better our accountants are
going up so you cannot expect much
enthusiasm for the reform of the part of
the miners I think this is one of the
inescapable reasons why successful
market reforms meet opposition and
produce this content because people can
no longer about the changes in time they
care about their relative positions how
to the digital human nation this is not
to say that one should avoid reforms
because if you do not reform and you
inherit a banker p commoner you are
going to be everybody's going to be
discomfort after wire because it can and
will be continued to collapse so the
choice is between a productive
discontent and unproductive this
compared so the better to choose
productive discontent this is the say to
reform from the point of view of the
nation and the from the individual point
of view and perhaps I would finish with
that leaving a lot of other issues for
the discussion hopefully thank you very
much
we'll open it up for questions
market for example number one why he
people tend to banks in Poland is
imploring and of course notes
pathetically good because not necessary
hey what is interested poland of course
earth question in germany and here is
second question is why he fall on the so
expensive Freddie I experienced this few
weeks ago 74 and send a person in Poland
they say about you that you the spire of
legal class I'm asking permission to
father Isaac Isaac yes i can tell i can
hit each row of course this is a second
problem and why bank
fallout is survivor rally the Polish
citizens are not customers in banks but
look like petitioners I experience again
in few with for example polish social
security number which must be in box
identity development play on human
tissue make account i will not talking i
wanna be for a second example we need
customers in for anita few ID cards here
is one a car ppm with picture and you
choose a pin number in poland is a few
identification card where you do at
window in time it's awesome the second
one is Etienne and they had a question
piece this is a question why is supposed
I pyramid because this loop thinking is
type of rehab socially because I
remember and I made the disposal account
with excuse me I practice going right
we've gone far enough zero he can't
remember are the Russians and extra he
goes right it sorry I think he's N
equals 1 wideout other questions he
can't remember about why is it
requesting and in time of communities
and this was our account the market but
because i didn't pay anything extra
0.0 ones yeah I know if you and password
but I think your basic question is why
Poland is not us and Switzerland and
because you refer to the differences
between let's support the number of
identification Paul Sneed compared to
the US and clicking the gank easily
Poland is not at the US and Paul it is
not yet the Switzerland but Poland first
much better than are the post-communist
countries and this is the right
comparison could you use a piece be
quiet yeah okay so and there are
nonsensical comparisons and insensitive
comparisons and nonsensical comparisons
just to take a chosen aspect of reality
and compared let's say with the best
countries with respect to the banks at
the beginning her there were no banks
Holland was not Switzerland in 1999
planet was communism there are
institutions called banks like I have a
lot to do with banks be no and they were
basically two ways as it was confirmed
the Central European Way and the Russian
world the Russian way consisted in
delaying privatization and preserving
the state ownership and look at Russia
there's a banking sector dominated by
huge state-owned banks girl bank and
many smaller private banks but secondly
this is not a very efficient sector yet
and then you have a center European Way
which is not only poll entities to Czech
Republic Slovakia Hungary Bulgaria
Romania every country they decided after
some hesitation not to delay
privatization of the banks but if you
want to privatize you must have realized
that at the beginning there was no
capital
and expertise how many bankers the way
in Poland for you so if you wanted to
privatize in a professional way you have
open tenders and international
institutions entered and they usually
both the banks so we have important a
banking sector which is compared to the
Russia magnificent where majority of
capital is owned by various institutions
from the worst that we create about
diversification so that there is no just
bank banks for German about too heavy
Jeremy ET la us portugal diversification
you have an even higher percentage of
foreign banks in hungary slovakia czech
republic i think what god is approaching
this so you have to choose you have no
choice of swiss banking at the beginning
this was excluded you have to choose I
the Russian strategy or polish center
European strategy Thanks well we have
choosen Central European strategy
atticus work very well compared to the
Russian storage interest rates is a I
don't know what's your personal credits
credits story but for sure it's not like
that everybody gets credit interest
rates have declined very much depending
if you compare to debt the interest
rates ten years ago because deflect
inflation decline client recite depend
on the rate of inflation which is reduce
a special after two thousand year 2000
and the efficiency of banking of
competition and I assure you there is a
lot of studies which show that when
banks think sector is dominated by
state-owned bank you have higher
interest rates for the consumer because
they bank is state-owned banks are
inefficient and this is where they have
much higher margins because they have to
cover the costs
ok
well if the common as much lower per
capita income they advance campus and
people are free to move you'll have
there something which has happened in
Spain 30 years ago in Portugal and
Greece fortunately people are free i am
not saying the day and very happy that
people are giving patented understand
they are exercising their choice the
main point is how many would return the
net migration and this is dependent
mostly on one factor no special
propaganda would work no exhaustion's it
would depend on how fast Poland would
develop economically so how fast this
gap will be reduced and the rate of
long-run growth the pension reforms like
privatizing competing privatization
which is still needed in Poland like
removing bureaucratic objects to
business which is called delegation like
strengthening important public
institutions like central bank like a
very supervisions public administration
back of course preserving low inflation
which is the key so if you reform you
reduce this gap if you reduce the
outflow of Poland this is why blogging
reforms is very unpatriotic very
unpatriotic first of all because it ha
it has the country in many ways it
lowers their the rate of at which
standard of living is growing and it
also increases the rate at which the
younger people to leave the country so
to pick up non reformers is very stupid
yes
well this is a classical question I
obtained very important question
classical obtained at every meeting
because with the benefit of hindsight
you know more pressure for you know you
can read about him it's a lot of
research first of all not only Oh
expression experience belt of the
research I now points out that the
strategy which we adopted in Poland
which consisted in trying to move on a
broad front at the rapid speed was a
good one in the sense that you cannot
find out other strategies which would be
very different which would work better
know they work worse if you interrupt
reforms if you are very slow than the
economy and society suffers so as far as
the word strategy is concerned I think
it has proven itself as I said nobody
you cannot expect that everybody would
be enthusiastic you have a living proof
yet but what's aesthetics of balls you
see that I think that in Poland we
should have if possible to reform the
physical sight even more than we did the
social spending was not trimmed enough
but again he said we inherited the
economy which was going bankrupt bust
inflation adapted to twenty forty
percent a month there was no budget in a
girl in the mud poland was bankrupt
because he was hiding in that which was
not being serviced people so and you
have to prepare the program so certain
things said with the benefit of
hindsight you kept secret a certain
things which one would have tried to do
better if one refers guitar
you
Oh
first let me say that the extent of
privatization in relative terms as a
percentage of economy had to be in
current incomparable lava that in any
Western countries because they in
Britain had mrs. starch's started to
privatize stayed on sector arbitrary was
responsive accounting for about twenty
percent or less when central eastern
european countries started to privatize
they inherited they had almost hundred
percent it's a completely different
problem and they did not have where I
developed financial markets so they
could not use only the classical
techniques of privatization March March
larger did a good problem in Poland I'm
us a privatization when slowly than I
wanted to why because they were
political there was a there were a
political obstacle paralyzation there
were delays pretty easily there were
demagogues who forgot what was socialism
and they started to play state-owned
enterprises had said that so it slowed
it down it did not happen these
enterprises quite the reverse is true I
can see that there are some people from
Poland and some of them seem to remember
sometimes those who remember would
remember that we have had enterprise
which was very popular under socialism
and the name of this enterprise was
paddocks who remembers bebexo where this
was polished Barry Oscar this was well
John II don't know this was a network of
shops which offered western boots like
bananas jeans Rotom johnnie walker etc
cars for dollars or coupons based on
dollars of hard currency and this was
popular and this enterprise paddocks has
initially extremely good position
because it was a good mark good friend
good brand it could be successful but it
does not exist well sparox they went
bankrupt why
because privatization was bought and he
perish could not resist competition for
private companies so its market was
taken all the publix disappeared so
delay in privatization is usually very
harmful to people who work in a given
enterprise because they have to look for
another job and also for the budget
because yoga's last man usually gets
less money if you private as later look
at shipyards yes even the gang shipyard
cool which resisted privatization the
people thought heroic times and memory
is enough it's not enough coming back so
actual privatization Poland was slowly
again we had planned because of
political obstacles even though i think
it was quite successful their scope of
special privatization program so free of
charge privatize a based based on
coupons in poland was smaller than we
expected a much smaller that sir than in
czech republic or slovakia and the share
of more classical waves of privatization
we are we are strategic investors
especially the world's probably hire
them in you know a in some other
countries the empirical research versus
adventures that on average privatized
enterprises are much more efficient than
non private enterprises and also
enterprises privatized with the
participation of foreign home in foreign
direct investors more efficient and
dynamic there and Sam enterprise which
are privatized with different methods
Oh
because there's a completely different
Commission so there's a confusion I have
testified well maybe I was invited to
the Polish Parliament let says Arabic
Finance Commission does normal but what
was striking Poland the last year was
completely exceptional I pathological
and I can see that people confuse these
things because in Poland we have an
instrument of a special investigative
condition which is based on the Penal
Code so this is not not a normal
Commission and in Poland there was an
attack upon the Independence of the
central bank last year it was related to
the fact that the central banker in
Poland the charm of the central bank is
the same time used to be the chairman of
the banking supervision and the banking
supervision was considering an important
case an application of unicredit bank
for a merger and experts legal experts
in banking supervision has analyzed this
application came to the conclusion they
got no legal objection that the law
requires to say yes however the
then-existing the previous government
started to put the pressure public
pressure upon the central bank putting
my modest person done to say no even
though there was no legal grounds done
so they did not like independent
institution we resisted and in revenge
and this is the first time in Poland
they they passed the resolution in the
parliament to convene a special
investigative condition which is based
on Penal Code this is not a normal
condition and this commission was
recognized as non-constitutional by all
practical all constitutional experts in
poland but nevertheless it was passed
which showed the contempt with the
previous government for the constitution
which is the highest law of the country
what about the rule of law why is this
condition was convened
there was an application there was an
objection sent to their constitution
tribunal is claiming that this is
against the Constitution but
Constitutional Tribunal took time it was
known that ten days before the date at
which the Constitution trigger was to
give its verdict as a central bank again
got a request not on the appeal in front
of the Commission and I have to analyze
what would mean from the point of view
of Independence of the central bank not
my modest person I was at a private
person I was sharing the central bank
which has to be independent because
without independency cannot defend the
stability of money and if I went I would
create a faithful president because
every success of nine on any pretext
would be summoned in front of such a
commission which is televised live and
has nothing to do with investigating but
everything to do with putting a dirt the
blame like a question how much money
have you stolen 1 billion or 10 million
this is the kind of Investigation so I
said no that I was not going to appear
because this would implicate this will
destroy our demand independence of the
central bank I knew that this is my last
year in office so it is not personal it
turned out that 10 days later
Constitution trigonal recognize this
resolution as contrary to the
Constitution but nevertheless the
previous government again has again in
violation in the second violation of the
Constitution convened in other
Commission yes okay I really
his race and good majority that was
necessary in recent months central bank
you can raise in two trips I want to get
your opinion on the exchange
the head of the central minority but I
composition has changed in that sense
that is a new chairman but this is the
only change their nine other members
were the same as last year but this was
a difficult decision because I knew that
it's not typical but I thought that
sometimes if you are feel very strongly
about something you have to act in such
a way and I believe that all the
available information then should edge
the monetary council to raise interest
rates on time because it's very easy to
raise interest rates the informations
already exceeding your target but you
are not paid for doing that you are paid
for being farsighted they wanted the
council to be farsighted and then I was
in the minority well I think the
developments which happen later rather
validated my position that the reverse
is true
this I don't I don't want to comment
further ok so John
see
so asking her that it's possible to
abandon communism it's possible to
understand understand well first of all
if you say privatizing for the sake of
privatizing here a way of condoning
convenience saying privatization is bad
for a second I not we commenting on your
country without don't know another I am
only saying that the essence of
privatization is a removal of political
owners of empty trash if there are
owners are political even if they are
the best persons let us assume there are
angels even angels under the political
incentive would harm the enterprise for
example if a politician has an ultimate
power and he wants to be popular then he
would try to build a factor in his
electoral district even if this does not
make an economic science there are many
many cases like that and this is against
their economic rationale in calculation
so privatisation meaning k removal a of
not political owners by private owners
being institutions or private person in
Savannah the most important probably the
most important reform away from
communism because was on what is
ultimately common is a concentration of
political power both over the economy
and non-economic issues and a very
important part of this concentration was
state ownership which is the political
power over enterprises what is about
communism power but economy and the
communist government is becoming
capitalistic in China most economies
already private and China's much more
open than India China has attracted to
five times as much foreign direct
investment is India and Chinese exports
are fine things lots of India so China
is not an exception
but now
well thanks to my parents first the
genes and they're not bringing so i am
very grateful to them so gone now but if
you accept certain job you would know
what they are accepting if you accept
being a fireman you should not be
surprised that sometimes its patron at
pretty hot that's essence now either I
not saying that head forcing everything
of course not but I was fond of reading
economic history and Fran economic
history and history in general that
reformers are very needed but not very
popular with along in the short run the
longer and is different mrs. Thatcher
even though she's safe Britain
economically was brutally attacked I
remember I was in Britain and my mass of
English language that much to be desired
and I have seen various inscription of
the walls and there was always been
named torture and I asked my British
friends what does it mean these other
words they were ashamed to say so you
should realize that what's the sort of
it is not this is not to say you one can
justify you know action there and should
not justify those who block reform hard
people especially for people but you
should not be surprised and second
one should know whose opinions you
respect and there are few people whose
opinions you respect now you cannot
respect opinions of all the people and
for example i was asked out that and
that some of them are already out of
Parliament said that in depth well how
do you react I have to prepare my other
in advance our users say but this is a
throne so you know if you work the
government and responsive for reforms
you have to develop an attitude of a
biologist you look at nature and in
nature there are various species last
now more is and said I would reform the
social spending more
well that's very interesting that people
who probably didn't ever live on the
farm Department know we have first aid
their own farms call horse in Poland
which were extremely wasteful as
everywhere and they could have survived
on if you continue to subsidize them
which means printing money you could not
do that and we didn't subsidize them
because they would be as I said this
would mean you continue a sort of
socialism and of course they could not
survive but he have introduced a special
program of restructuring which very apt
altimet was a success but there was a
lot of complaints but you know lots of
complaints sometimes are related to
reforms so what do you do you pull money
if you pull money you are back at the
square wall last last question from from
the left may be right if you are
referred to
what
Oh
I was speaking about Poland I was
speaking about Russia but I don't
remember 82 and I all spin about what
credits given by the central bank I'm
just to be sure I was out of government
but still I don't remember that I I'm
afraid we are confusing countries which
happens but if you're asking me about
was it was reforming that you should
have should compare and then you compare
one now and they are wrong this is thus
not a part of shock therapy and I don't
remember any such program but even if
this was true this is still wrong to try
to pick up sam think we should think all
this would compromise the whole program
because you have to compare you take
countries which were similar at the
beginning and then you see how they fare
have the 5 10 years and then you see
that countries are four more in a better
situation this empirical fact you have
to be empirical okay I think I really
have
finish this now I wanted to back our
speaker first of all for say I'm not an
expert on Central European genomics but
Sir I really think you gave some very
specific very expert questions and I
think this is partly perhaps because of
cpap because there are some quite
advanced courses which i think i've
imported this building so as far as I
can make out it was a very lively
discussion but stimulated of course by
your introduction so thank you very much